Nekem ez nagyon jó visszacsatolás volt,
és önbizalmat is adott, hogy lehet ezen
a pályán menni előre. És azóta én
képviselem ezt a szemléletet, hogy mi
nem adománykén, mert mi nem vagyunk
koldusok. Mi tudásunkkal,
hozzájárulásunkkal,
a szolgáltatói jellegünkkel tudunk
hozzájárulni a cégnek a profit
növeléséhez, a sales számeinak a
növeléséhez. És annyira, hogyha ezek a
partnerek, mivel ezek sales cégek
alapvetően, ők tulajdonképpen a az ő
pénzük is ezáltal nőtt.
>> Sziasztok! Üdvözöllek a navigátor
podcastben. Következő vendégem Dr. Saraf
Hassan, a budapesti Műszaki Egyetemnek a
rektora. Vele volt egy iszonyatosan jó
beszélgetésem. [zene]
Arról beszéltünk, hogy az újonnan
elvállalt mandátumában hogyan alakítja
és hogyan fogja átalakítani a budapesti
műszaki egyetemnek a működési formáját.
Többek között beszéltünk [zene] a
budapesti Műszaki Egyetem jövőjéről,
arról, hogy hogyan is érdemes tanulni és
mit érdemes tanulni, milyen
nehézségekkel küzd meg, mint rektor és
milyen is lesz a jövő 50 év múlva. Ha
tetszett ez az epizód, akkor kérlek,
iratkozz fel a csatornákra, esetleg adj
egy lájkot, vagy hagyj egy kommentet.
Ezzel segíted az algoritmust, hogy minél
több emberhez eljusson ez a beszélgetés.
Köszönöm szépen.
Köszönöm szépen, hogy elvállaltad a
meghívást, Hassan.
Főleg az, mert rengeteg kérdésem van így
egy olyan egyetemnek a rektora
rektorához, aki aki egy ekkora
közösséget vezet 3000 alkalmazottal és
20000 diákkal.
De nem tudom megkerülni ezt a kérdést,
hogy fel ne tegyem, hogy
a Hassan az nem egy tipikus ősmagyar
név.
Hogyan lehetséges, hogy hogy te vezeted
a BMW-t ebben a pillanatban? Egy kicsit
mesélnél- erről a múltról, hogy hogyan
kerültél Magyarországra, és hogy ez eg
ha nem tudom, hogy össze lehet-e
foglalni egy pár perc alatt ezt a
hatalmas életutat, de hogy hogy azért
azt a kíváncsiságot
elégítsük ki így a a hallgatók részére.
Köszönöm szépen a meghívást.
Valóban a a használ név ez nem ősmagyar
név. Bár a van névnap. Ez február 23-án.
Tehát ez
>> van Hassan magyar név. Hogyne, hogyne.
Valaki csak nézze a névnapkalendárt,
csak azért biztonság kedvéért ezt
érdemes említeni.
>> Szoktam is kapni köszöntéseket a névnap
alkalmából, de komolyra fordítva a szót,
én Libanonban születtem 18, és fél éves
koromban, majdnem 19
állami ösztöndíjesként jöttem
Magyarországra, BMR-re.
Egy évig nyelvve tanultam, mert egy
betűt se tudtam magyarul.
Ez 1986 szeptember 20-án volt, tehát
azért jövőre lesz 40 éve, tehát négy
évtized. Az első év a nyelvtanulással
telt áll, utána 87-ben
kerültem be a missek egyetemre,
villamosmérnöki karra és 92-ben ott
végeztem.
Akkor még vörös diplomának hívták azet
kitüntetéses
diplomával, és ott maradtam
doktorandusznak és én nyugodtan
mondhatom, az teljes létrád végigjártam.
Az, hogy hogyhogy én vezetem,
ezt ezt nagyon egyszerűen tudom mondani.
Beadtam egy pályázatot tavaly. Tavaly
volt a választás
2024-ben,
és a szenátus nekem szavazott több mint
kétos többséggel bizalmat. Így
megtisztelő volt számomra ez a ez a
bizalom, amit kaptam az Egyetem
szenátusától.
És
2024 július 1-től vezetem rektörként a
Missek egy Egyetemet. Ennek a
>> kicsit több mint egy éve. Igen,
>> igen,
>> igen. De azalatt az egy év alatt ez sok
minden történt.
>> Igen, igen. Így a tehát gyakorlatilag te
tényleg így végigjártad a ranglétrát,
kezdve egészen diáktól fel most a
rektori szintig, és amint utánad
kutattam, így felmerült bennem a kérdés,
és aztán bizonyítékot is kaptam rá, hogy
nem csak jogtalanul, hogy éreztél egy
elutasítást azért, mert Hassannak
hívnak.
Például hallottam ilyen kritikákat, hogy
hát magyart nem kaptatok rektornak.
>> Én is láttam ilyen bejegyzést a
Facebookon. Én ezeket a bejegyzéseket
helyen kezelem. Én a
hát a közösségi médiának a velejárója,
tehát a gyerekeimet szokta idegesíteni,
mert a kisebbik gyerekem érzékenyre rá,
és mindig láttad mit írtak? Mondom mit?
Igazuk van. És akkor ilyenkor ilyen hely
helyén kezelem.
Ha ezt komolyan kell venni, én egy olyan
közösségben élek, ahol azt mondom,
egészséges, sose éreztették velem. Az
egyetemi közösség a legjobb bizonyíték
arra, hogy nem voltam egyedüli jelölt,
tehát többen voltunk.
És
mint ilyen, ez demokratikus választás,
mint ilyen voltak úgy kampányfórumok,
ahol az ember ismertethette a programját
a közösséggel. hallgatókkal meg
dolgozókkal egyaránt. És ezek után
történt a választás. Tehát az egyetem
döntött, az Egyetem egy autonóm
intézmény döntött arról, hogy ki
vezesse, és ha gond lett volna azzal,
hogy hogy hívnak, akkor biztos nem
szavaztett volna rám. És azért én
köszönettel tartozok a kollégáimnak
azért a bizalom azért a bizalomért, amit
amit nekem szavazták, nekem megadtak
tavaly. És ami még fontosabb, én világos
pályázatot adtam be. Én azt mondtam, nem
akarom állami formába hagyni az
egyetemet, állammal közösen, de nem
állami, vagy teljesen állami formában az
egyetemet. Szeretném áttranszformálni a
működési modellünket egy korszerűbb
modellre. A BME a hitem szerint én
fanatikusan hiszek a BM képességeiben,
különben nem vállalkoztam volna erre a
feladatra. Nekem ez nem egy poszt vagy
egy dicsőség, ez egy szolgálat, mert én
úgy érzem, Magyarországtól általában és
a BML-től speciálisan nagyon sokat
kaptam. Mindent, amit elértem, szinte a
BML-nek köszönhetem, meg az országnak
értelemszerűen, hiszen én nem itt
születtem. Most volt az október 23-ai
központi nemzeti ünnepség, és
a beszédemben azt mondtam már, 44
évtizede hazámnak tekintem
Magyarországot. Tehát nekem ott
Libanonban születtem, de azért 18 kontra
lassan 40 év. Ez ebből érződik, hogy a
hova kötődök.
Az ember nem felejti el, nem tagadja
meg, amit ami ami hogy hon hol
született, hol élt, hol nevelkedett 18
éves korig. De amit kaptam
Magyarországtól, én az egyetemnek
akármit teszek, nem tudom visszaadni ezt
a nagy hálát, amit amit kaptam az
egyetemtől. az Egyetem nevével, az
Egyetem környezetében
értem el, amit elértem, és
úgy érzem, eljött az idő, hogyha nekem
van egy elképzelésem,
az Egyetem közössége képviselve a
szenátusban szavazott nekem bizalmat.
Nem csak a személyemről szavazott a
szenátus, hanem a programomról is. A
programomban le voltak írva, hogy én
milyen intézkedéseket, milyen lépéseket
fogok tenni. Így senki sem lepődik meg,
hogy tavaly júliusban, július elején
kaptam meg a a akkor jelent meg a
közlőben a a az én megbízásomnak a a
híre, és azóta vagyok én vezetője az
egyetemnek.
És egy év alatt merem mondani, bő egy
év, kicsit több mint egy év, de pontosan
június 23-ig lezártuk ezt az első
feladatot,
miszerint áttranszformáltuk az egyetemet
egy államháztartási szervtől, egy tiszta
állami intézményből,
egy
cég fenntartású vagy vállalatfenntartású
modellé transzformáltuk át.
Mi a jelentősége ennek a a
transzformációnak?
>> Mi fontos ez?
>> Nézd, mondok több példát, de hogy és ne
csak a pénz, a pénzt tegyük fel a végén
a pénzre is fogok visszatérni,
mert itt nem csak a pénz,
az államháztartás olyan szabály, hogy
január 1től december 31-ig tud
gondolkodni az ember. Pénzforgalmi
szemlélet, amit elköltöttem
december 31-ig. Ezt elköltöttem, a többi
ott marad, mint maradvány.
Valójában ez nem maradvány,
mert vannak olyan projektek, amik éppen
akkor befutottak, ezek tulajdonképpen
terheltek, csak az államháztartás nem jó
gazdálkodási forma,
mert jó az állami világnak, de olyan
intézménynek, mint a Műegyetemnek,
ahol ahol a bevétel látható arányban
van, ahol pályázat, ipar, hallgatói,
külföldi hallgatói bevétel, ez látható
számban van.
Hogyha így nézem, akkor majd már
átlépjük az 50%-ot,
akkor akkor ez sok mindenre ad válasz,
hogy miért rossz nekünk az
államháztartáson belüli gondolkodás.
A másik volt nekünk egy én
nyomortáblának szoktam hívni, ez a
közalkalmazotti bértábla, ami szerint
olyan szintű, hogy megalázó volt a bér a
a bértábla szerint. Jó, persze, valaki
Ja, így nem lehet kirúgni a kollégát.
Itt nem a miért kell a negatív példákkal
kezdeni? Mi ki akar bárkit kirúgni?
Minden értékes emberre szükség van a
műegyetemen.
>> Ezt most arra írtad, hogy a
közalkalmazottakat nehezebb kirúgni.
>> Nehezebb kirúgni. Több szabadsága van,
több szabadnapja van egy évben is,
mintogyha ez július augusztus, ez nem
történne semmi. Tehát ez a fajta langyós
víz a kor szellemével ez nem tud
összeegyeztethető lenni. Azért én úgy
gondolom, az államháztartás, ez az egész
megközelítés, az állam nem jó gazdag és
nem akarok senkit bántani, de az állam
ez ez ott van kész egy állami
a harmadik, ami szintén fontos, hogy
ha tényleg bízunk a BML képességeiben,
akkor miért nem vetjük magunkat egy
teljes mély alapú szerződés alá? Ez volt
a megközelítés. Ez egyfajta kihívás is
egybe. Annyira hiszek, fanatikusan
hiszek a BML képességeiben, hogy azt
mondom, ez nem okoz gondot a BML-nek, ez
a fajta megközelítés.
Tehát szerződök az állammal, továbbra is
az állam a főfinanszírozom,
továbbra is a képzések ingyenesek,
illetve
tandimentesek. Itt attól függ, hogy hogy
nézem. Persze, aki önköltséges, aki
önköltséges, az önköltségesként év be,
de aki államiendesként kerül be, neki
nem kerül semmibe. Továbbra is
szerződésem van az állammal. Tehát a a
hallgatóknál ez nem érződik.
Csak akkor akkor ha tényleg hiszünk ebbe
a képességbe, hogy mi minőségi és
mennyiségi kritériumoknak is tudunk
eleget tenni, akkor vessük alá magunkat
egy olyan szerződés alá, ami jóval több
pénz, két-két háromszorosa a pénznek ez
bejön. Ja, ha nem teljesít, akkor nem
jön be. Ezt gyanítom azért könnyen nem
fogadták a a az oktatók, merthogy ha
addig azt szokták meg, hogy egy ilyen
intézményben voltak, ahol gyakorlatilag
nincsenek következményei az
alulteljesítésnek, ebben a pillanatban
most már abban az, hogy hogyha egy
profitorientált közegbe kéne néhány
tanár megállja a helyét, azért kétlem,
hogy megállná. Legalábbis így nézem a a
románt tanügyet.
Nem is profitorientált, azt még nem
tekintjük annak, hanem hanem vannak
vállalások, amiket eleget kell tenni,
hogyha ez egy kicsit messze van még a
profit orientáltságtól.
>> Furcsa módon, hogyha megnézem a
decemberi szavazást, amikor a szenátus
döntött erről, hogy mert kell nekem
mindenképpen kellett szenátus döntés
ahhoz, hogy kezdeményezzük az állam
felé, hogy mi más modellbe szeretnénk
működni, akkor 85% fölött volt a
támogatás. Tehát biztos van egy réteg,
aki fél a változástól, és akármit mondok
nekik, félni fog,
>> de ez meglepően kevés. Én arra
gondoltam, hogy nagyobb lesz ez a réteg.
>> Nem, nem, hogyha bármilyen, ha
végigköveti, egy éven keresztül, napról
napra követtem végig, nagyon kevés ez a
populáció, mert sokan sokan úgy voltak
már vele, hogy mozduljunk valamilyen
irányba, ne maradjunk, ez a langyos víz.
És több fiatal generáció, meg idősebb
korosztály is, hogy úgy gondolta, hogy
már ha az E-t nem tud testeni, és akkor
tényleg ilyen ilyen feltételekkel tudunk
szerződni az állammal, menjünk ebbe az
irányba. Ez nem igaz. Ez a hála Istennek
a sajtóba is az jött, nem voltak ilyen
ilyen nagy hangok. Volt volt egy réteg,
akik bizonyos értelemben akár politikai
magyarázattal magyarázták az egészet. Én
azt szoktam mondani, ki ismert tudja,
nekem egy vallásom, egy politikám, úgy
hívják, hogy BML, nem érdekel a
politika, mint ilyen. És én de egy
dolgot nem tagadhatok, hogy a miniszter
úr, Ankó Balázs miniszter úr, a
minisztérium aparátos Varga Bajos
Veronika államtitkár asszony, akik
vezetik ezt az ágazatot, partnerek
voltak abban, hogy ezt a lépést
megtegyük. Ők támogatóak voltak.
Miniszter úr vitte a kormány elé ezt a
döntést, mert kellett kormány döntés
ezzel kapcsolatban.
és az ő segítségük nélkül ez nem tudott
volna végigmenni. És ahogy ő is
fogalmazott, ő is szeretne látni egy
olyan környezetet, akkor hogy még
sikeresebb a BML. És ha én tényleg úgy
tekintek a BML-rel, mint mint a nemzet
műszaki egyeteme,
akkor enival tartozunk neki, hogy
találjuk ezt a modellt, ami működik ott.
És azért, hogy ne véletlenszerűen
mondjuk azt, hogy találtunk egy modellt.
Ez ez le van vezetve, le tudom vezetni.
A rektöri pályázatom ez egy vízióról
szól. Én hova szeretném
vinni, hol szeretném látni öt év múlva a
a mandátumom az első ciklusom végéig az
egyetemet. A az egyetem most 200 a most
kezdtük meg a 244.
tanévet, tehát hat év múlva, amikor 250.
születésnapjára az egyetemnek, akkor
hova szeretnénk eljutni? Ezek víziós
elemek, amiket meg lehet valósítani.
Csak ezeket csak úgy lehet
megvalósítani, ha a világ forgási
sebességének megfelelően tudunk reagálni
a változásukra, az eseményekre. És erre
az államztartás nem alkalmas. Azért
nekem egy rugalmasabb működés kell.
>> Ez egyik oldalról szükséges a vízió,
mert mert kell, hogy tervezzünk. másik
oldalról annyira gyorsan változik a
világunk, hogy hogy szinte mindegy, hogy
mit tervezünk. Vár nem, ha tervezünk
valamit, biztos nem az fog megtörténni,
mert fogváltoz nem értünk egyet. azért
nem értünk egyet,
>> mert amit a vízióba írtunk, nem azt
mondjuk, hogy lesz milyen szinten lesz a
mesterséges intelligenciaor. Nem nem
arról szólt a vízió, hogy a robotizáció
mit fog behozni az életünkben. Nem arról
szólt, hogy a a képzési tartalom hogyan
változik, hogyan nem változik. Ez ezeket
elég gyorsan kell változtatni és követni
a változásokat. A vízió arról szól, hova
akarok jutni. Tehát az egyetemet a világ
rangsorban hol szeretném látni? A magyar
gazdaságban milyen szerepet töltsön be?
A magyar KKV szektornak hogyan segítsen?
A magyar közép közoktatásnak vagy a
középiskolásoknak milyen segítségeket
nyújt, hogy sikerre tudjon vinni? Milyen
innovációs ökoszisztémát épít az
egyetem. És ebben a gyönyörű kampuszon a
hiába van több épülete, több mint 100
éves, ez gyönyörű kampuszunk van. Ebben
a kampuszban hogy tudunk egy ilyen
innovatív életet lehelni? Ezek a víziós
elemek függetlenül attól, hogy milyen
mesterséges intelligencia és robotizáció
kerül be a mindennapi életünkben. Tehát
ahhoz, hogy elérjük ezt a víziót, én nem
nem tudunk egy hónapos meg másfél
hónapos meg 40 egyeztetéssel válaszolni.
Ezt úgy hívják a soft én szoftveres
vagyok a responzív azért vagyok a
digitális székely vagy közkeföldi
konferencián, mert ez a szakmám is, és
ez szívem ez ez közelesik, és már négy
éve járok ide. Nem először vagyok itt.
Tehát a szoftver iparban azt mondjuk
responzív. Tehát a szoftver responzív, a
szervezet is responzív. Nem akarok ilyen
nagy szavakat agilis, tehát responzív,
tud válaszolni a változásokra és a vízió
elérése érdekében mennyi mindent kell
még változtatni nekünk belül ahhoz, hogy
k
>> beszéljünk erről a vízióról. Te hogyan
látod hat év múlva az egyetemet? Be
vegyünk bizonyos aspektusokat, amit
említettél. Világranglista, az iparral
való kapcsolat. Vegyük sorra ezeket.
Most mi
mi egy mérnöki egyetem vagyunk, bár
műszök és gazdaságtudomány van gazdasági
képzésünk, de a műegyetem arról híres,
hogy mérnökképzőközpontja
a nemzetnek. Tehát ez nem nem mondok
újat azzal. Azért nálunk az engineering
meg a technology területre kell
fókuszálnunk, azokkal mérjük magunkat.
minket nem szabad a tudomány
egyetemekkel együttmérni, mert ők
szélesebb spektrumot fednek le, mint mi.
Na most ha így nézem, jelenleg
231. helyen vagyunk a QS engineering és
technoló technológiai rangsorban. Na
most ha így nézem, én az első 100-ban
szeretném látni a műegyetemet a az 50. a
250. születésnapjára.
Ez egy cél, ez a vízióelem.
Mondok más példát, ami én úgy gondolom,
a BME példá példát tud mutatni több
egyetemnek, hogy milyen szoros
együttműködése az iparral, de a BM
magához képest ez gyenge.
A többihez képest mi jól állunk,
magunkhoz képest nem. Szeretném, hogy a
magyar gazdaság motorja lenne a BML-nek.
Szeretnék minden ilyen stratégiai
projektben a BML legyen benne, és nem
pénz kérdése. Ez a tudás, ami a BM-en
van, ez szerintem
nincsen kellőképpen
felszínra hozva. Ez a tudás, ami a BM-en
van, többet ér. Így a üzleti világban
azt mondják, az opportunity cost, tehát
elmolasztott lehetőségeknek az ára. Én
úgy érzem, veszteséget termelek az
egyetemnek, hanem aknázom ki ezeket a
lehetőségeket. Tehát én két területre
mennék. Egyik tudománysíkon megyünk itt
a rangsorban, a másik a mérnöki, a
gazdasági, a fejlesztési, a
megvalósítási
a területen. Mennyire szeretnék
kússzereplő lenni a magyar gazdaságban,
mint BM.
Tudom, hogy többen kicsit
félreértelmezik a felső oktatás
szerepét. Mi egy szolgáltató szektor
vagyunk, ami azt jelenti, azért
kutatunk, hogy minőségi megvalósításokat
tudjunk csinálni, azért kutatunk, hogy
hozzájáruljunk a világ fejlődéséhez.
azért kutatunk, hogy ezekből az
eredményekből tanulságokat vonjunk le,
és ezt forgassuk vissza, invesztáljuk
vissza a az oktatásba. És a legfontosabb
feladatunk szolgáltatóként a régiónak és
a hazai gazdaságnak termelni a
talentumokat, a a a mérnököket, a persze
közgazdászok is, de alapvetően a
mérnökök vannak. Tehát a STEM terület a
műszaki informatikai természettudomány
területen.
Mi szeretnénk ezt a szerepet betölteni,
amit tulajdonképpen
ezt a szerepet,
ez kicsit lehet, hogy bántó lesz, de
lehet, hogy nem mi találtuk ki. A nemzet
adta nekünk már ezért a 243 éves múlt.
Ami mögöttünk van. Ez egyértelműen
bizonyítja azt, hogy amikor a József
Nádor létrehozta a két pillérét a a
gazdasági és műszök területnek, mint a
Duna két oldalon, az egyértelmű volt,
hogy ebbe lát, és ez bölcs volt, mert
ebben látja a fejlődését a az iparnak,
az országnak, a gazdaságnak több
tekintetben. És ezt a szerepet nekünk be
kell töltenünk. Nincs más választásunk.
És ahhoz, hogy ezt betöltsük, akkor
szellemmével sminkelve, akkor szerintem
nincs más út. De ez az, ez az én
véleményem. Erről lehet, hogy mások
másképpen vélekednek, és szerencsére a a
közösség ennek az iránynak, ennek a
víziónak szavazott bizalma. Igen, itt ez
egy jó alkalom, hogy megemlítsem a cég
cégépítők podcastet, ha valaki nem
látta, egyrészt a te életedről egy picit
több szól, és ezért is nem mentem jobban
bele a a múltadba, hogy honnan jöttél.
Nagyon izgalmas volt a feleségemmel
meghallgattuk és egy ilyen egy ilyen
kett csináló, amikor eljöttél, akkor
pont bombázták a faludat, és
szóval egy egy hihetetlen életút van
mögötted. De nézzétek meg azt az
epizódot. Viszont egy dolgot még
kiemelnék abból az epizódból, ami nekem
nagyon tetszett, amikor külön
kihangsúlyoztad,
hogy amikor elmentél a Microsofthoz,
mindjárt megkérem, hogy meséld el a
történetet, elmentél a Microsofthoz és
mondtad, hogy adjanak 25 gépet, és de ez
nem adomány. És ez nem adomány, mert nem
koldusok vagyunk. És ez az önbecsülés,
amivel felszólaltál, engem meg érinted,
biztos vagyok benne a feleségemet is,
hogy erre az önbecsülésre annyira
szükségünk van, hogy így álljon hozzá a
a BMI, így álljon hozzá a tudományos
világ, hogy a tanárok nem éhenkórászok,
akik várják, hogy most valami adományt
kapjanak, hanem valójában az éllovasai a
technológiának, és és ott kell legyenek,
ahogy mondtad, a az ipar élén kell
legyünk, és minden fontos dologban benne
kell legyünk. Ö kezd elmesélnéd ezt a
Microsoftos történetet egy picit
részletesebben, és utána belekérdezek
egy dologba. Ö szerencsére még mindig
Microsoftnál van a a másik oldal, Merini
Ádamnak hívják, ha szabad itt neveket
mondani.
Akkor még friss volt a Microsoftnál ő,
és mondtam neki, hogy szeretnénk
bevezetni a Windows programozást,
Microsoft Windows programozást a
talanyagba,
és
mondta, jó, mondom, de nincs gép, kell
21 gép.
mondta, jó, mondom, adjatok 21 gépet,
szereljetek fel egy labort. Kiteszünk
egy táblát, hogy Microsoft támog által
támogatott labor.
És előzménye ennek a mondatomnak, mielő,
hogy azt mondom, én nem hiszek a koldus
modellben,
mert ez a szerelem egy oldalról
egyszerkétszer talán tud segíteni, de
hosszabb távon nem tud fenntartható
lenni.
És maradjunk a winwin, mert egy profit
orientált cég nem biztos, hogy érdekelt
lesz hosszú távon adományokba.
Én azt mondtam, nézzük meg, mit tudunk
adni mi a Microsoftnak. Nélkülünk a
Microsoft Magyarország nem tud gyorsan
fejlődni, mert mi ha mi képezzük most,
ha ezt a technológiát mi tanítjuk bent
az egyetemen, mi a szélszámok
növeléséhez is hozzájárulunk.
Tehát én kidomborítottam ezt a szerepet,
ezt az értéket, ami produkálunk a
partnercégnek.
És én nekem van egy elvem, hogy annyira
önző vagyok, hogy neked jól menjen, mint
partnerem, mert ha neked jól megy, jobb
kedvvel fogsz visszaforgatni a, mert
látod az eredményet az egésznek. És ez
volt a megközelítése a Microsoftnál.
És ami bennem düh volt, és hagyd valljam
be itt, amikor bekerültem 96-ban, 96
január 1-től vagyok főállás, mert előtt
a doktorandusz voltam a ugyanazon a
tanszéken, ugyan az egyetemen.
Mindenkitől azt hallottam, mi szegények
vagyunk, közalkalmazottak vagyunk, ha
már erről beszélünk. Fú, kicsi a bérünk,
tudtok nekünk segíteni abba. És engem ez
nagyon bosszantott ez a megközelítés. Én
azt gondoltam, de szerencsém volt, ezt
tegyük hozzá. Az idő egy nagyon fontos
faktor. Én egy olyankor tudtam ezt
képviselni, amikor a szoftver boom
elején voltunk. Ezt tegyük hozzá, mert
így ez együtt korrekt nézni. Nem, nem
csak én, mert én mit mondtam, hanem ez
fontos, ez időzítés is jó volt. Kedvező
volt a környezet, mert volt egy szoftver
boom, és ez a és közeledett ez a
nem Y2K, ez a a 2000 év probléma, amikor
nagyon sok szoftverest fontak be, ez
2000-ben. Hogy mi lesz akkor, ha
átváltunk 1999.
december 30 kén a 2000-reel és nagyon
sok szoftveres kellett az amerikai
piacra. Tehát voltak ilyen kedvezők,
hívjuk úgy, hogy makro feltételek.
És akkor ez könnyű volt, lehet, hogy nem
jó szó az, meglovagolni ezt könnyű volt
ezt ezt a felismerni ezt a helyzetet és
jókor mondani ez a megközelítés. És ami
becsületükre legyen mondva a Microsoft
kollégáknak, hogy láttak ebbe a
fantáziát. És tényleg ez az volt az első
labor. És emlékszem, amikor a a
mentorom, tusár professzorom is már
nyugodjon békében meghalt, előtte
mindent megtett akadémia satöbbi, hat
gépet szerzett be. Jön, bocsánat egy
tanársegéd, aki tegnap lépett be az az
egyetemen, most vettük föl, mert
tanársegéd most fejezte be a doktoriát,
azért már kopásból egy telefonnal intéz
21 gépet. egy kicsit akkor egy kicsit
ilyen ilyen nekem ez ez nagyon jó
visszacsatolás volt és önbizalmat is
adott, hogy lehet ezen a pályán menni
előre. És azóta én képviselem ezt a
szemléletet, hogy mi nem adományt
kérünk, mert mi nem vagyunk koldusok. Mi
tudásunkkal, hozzájárulásunkkal,
a szolgáltatói jellegünkkel tudunk
hozzájárulni a cégnek a profit
növeléséhez, a szélszámeinak a
növeléséhez. És annyira, hogyha ezek a
partnerek, mivel ezek szes cégek
alapvetően, ők tulajdonképpen a az ő
pénzjük is ezáltal nő. Tehát a
motiváltság ez megvolt. Erre szoktam
hívni, ilyen winwin szituáció mind a két
oldalban, mert én már nem koborgok egy
egy-két ilyen ilyen régi gépen, hanem a
legújabb gépeken
tudjuk tanítani a fiatalokat. és
elindult egyfajta PC
terjedés, akkor előtte azért ez ez nem
volt annyira elterjedve ez a személy
számítógép, de az időzítés is fontos. És
itt megjegyzek két dolgot. Elsőként az
én csoportomban mi vezettük be a Windows
programozást az egyetemi oktatásba és
kér az egész Európában h
>> és mi vagyunk elsők az én csoportomban,
aki a mobil programozás 98-ban Szimbián
akkor még a Nokia mobil Gold Ezében vagy
aranykorában volt. Mi voltunk akik
bevezették és emlékszem akik ilyen
kicsit konzervatívebbak, azt mondják, ez
játék lesz. Mondom, én hiszek ebbe a
játékba, és ez a játék fog dominálni. Ez
98-ban. És azért a a cégépítők podcastba
azt mondtam, azt hittük, hogy ez játék a
telefon.
Valóban játék, de komolyabb játék, mint
lett belőle, mint ahogy ahogy én is meg
mások is gondoltak kezdettől fogva. De
mi elsők között a szimbian programozást,
mobil programozást a a az el a az első
okostelefonokra mi vezettük be, mint
ilyen szinten, kurikulumként,
egyértemi tantárgyént, és nagyon
népszerű volt kezdettől fogva ez a
megközelítés.
Igen. Hát azt hiszem, hogy nem véletlen,
hogy hogy néha kívülről kell jöjjön
valaki és tükröt tartson nekünk, hogy
mennyire elkeskenyedhetünk, mennyire
elszomorodhatunk.
>> Én nemtem kívülről, én belülről írtam.
>> Hát úgy értem, Libanonból.
>> Igen, csak előtte volt 86-9 volt 10
évem, ahol nagyon erősen a magyar
levegőt szívtam, és az egyetemi millőt
tanultam. Lehet, hogy ez benne volt a
dologban, csak
azért is
mosolygok egy kicsit az erre a kérdés,
mert Libanonban a családom azt hiszi,
hogy ezt a vehaciát, amivel én ilyen
lelkesen beszélek egy dologról, ezt
magyaroktól tanultam, a magyarok azt
gondolják, hogy én onnan hoztam, és
[nevetés]
mindig nevetek ezen, hogy egyik se igaz,
mert nekem volt egy mentorom, aki aki
sokat támogatott kezdettől fogva, ő
felkarolt. Azt szoktam mondani, hogy nem
biológiai apám, tehát ez ennyire
támogatott, de azt szoktam mondani, hogy
mondd a véleményedet és amíg látsz, ne
aggódj. Tehát biztonságot éreztem és
bennem nem volt ez a félelem. Jaj, most
mi fog történni? Majd az újság
professzor megoldja, hogyha valami
probléma van. Tehát volt egy ernyőm, ami
ami nekem egy önbizalmat adott, és ez
sokat segíthet és azért lettem
hangosabb. Egyéb gyerekeim se hiszik el,
hogy ilyen szégyellős, ilyen
visszafogott voltam. A gyerekeim azt
mondják, apa, nem le nem tudjuk rólak
elképzelni. Pedig én az voltam. Csak ez
a bátorítás, amit kaptam a Tusá
professzortól, ez megfordította nekem a
a megközelítésemet.
És mivel ő az iparból jött vissza az
egyetemre, én mindig arra építettem az
életemet, hogy a műszökelyi egyetem nem
tud kéz a kéz nélkül, tehát kézz a kézbe
kell mennie iparral, különben nincs
jövője. Nekem ez a hitám. És és e és ezt
maximalizálni kell ezt a fajtágyűjt
működést. az ipar meg az egyetem között,
mert gondolom a ter, tehát a
tevékenységünk jellege is olyan, ez egy
műszaki tevékenység. Laborban születnek
az eredmények. Nem, nem csak cikkekben,
nem levecsülni akarom, félretesnelség,
csak itt a csinálni, így, így és agy,
nem tételezzük föl a táblánál, hanem
konkrét problémát oldunk meg. És ha
bevonjuk a hallgatókat ebbe ezekbe a
projektekbe a a valós projektekbe, a
konkrét ipari projektekbe, egy értékben
ez magasabb, kettő a business skill, az
hogy csapatskill, az hogy együtt
dolgozunk egy csapatban, határidőre
satöbbi. Ezt a nevelést meg kell adni a
gyerekeinknek, gyerekeink, mert az én
gyerekem is nálunk végzett, tehát a
hallgatóinknak. Tehát úgy érzem, ezt a
fajta magatartást, ezt a fajta
megközelítést is kell tanítani a
mérnököknek, és nem csak az, hogy a
legjobb megoldást találják ki, hanem
össze kell állnia az ökoszisztémának
ahhoz, hogy hogy tényleg sikeres
mérnökököt képezzünk. És bennem ez ez
kezdett megfogalmazódni egyre jobban és
egyre élesebben. És ez a dolog nem
változott 96 óta. Már lassan 30 éve ezt
képviselem.
És én amikor a Microsoftnak,
a Microsoftnak nem csak a utána amikor
már barátkoztunk nagyon sokszor Nokia is
a annyi 100 telefont pakolt ide a
legújabb telefonokat mindig ott, hogy
tessék hallgatók dolgozzatok. Kezdetben
elmondani lehetett erről, mert ezért nem
voltak elérhetőek, hogy nem voltak olyan
árban ezek a és nem volt ennyi
applikáció rajtuk. Itt a 98-as
évek elején
ről beszélünk. Tehát
abból a szempontból ez kellett ez az
ipari támogatás a háttérben, de
ugyanakkor mi csináltunk projekteket
mind a Microsoftnak, mind a Nokjának,
sőt a Microsoftnak olyan szinten, hogy a
fejlesztői konferenciáinak a tartalmát,
ilyen milyen demókat mutassuk be nekik,
az új technológiákat. Ezt mi a magyar
fejlesztői közösségnek mi szállítottuk
több éven keresztül, és amit ott
fejlesztettünk, véletlenül a laborokba
is bemutattuk a hallgatóknak. Tehát így
a hallgatók, és azért voltam ilyen,
bocsánat, hangos, vagy hangos volt tőlem
a szakmá ilyen formában, mert én azt
mondtam, ha most megérik egy technológia
és hiszünk benne, következő fél évben
bekerül a laborban. Ez annak köszönhető,
mert ennek az előnét is látjuk, és sok
pénzt kerestünk vele. Tehát itt ne ne
szerénykedjünk ebbe, pénzt is kerestünk
vele. És ez elindított egyfajta
megközelítést, amit mai napig is én
képviselek. És szeretném, hogy ez nem
csak az informatikában, az egész
egyetemen ez a
ez a gyors tempójú működés,
responzivitás, válaszoljunk gyorsan az
ipari igényekre, és nem látok olyan
műszaki területet, ahol nem tud ne
tudnánk ezt bevezetni, és én én meg
vagyok győződve. És ha visszatérve az új
modellre, az új modell viszont szabad
kezet ad ilyen formában szabad nem szól
bele az új modell.
Hogy mondjam?
egy fejű a rektör felel. Ő az első számú
vezető. Minden, én azt szoktam mondani
most, minden hiba nálam van, tőlem van.
Minden problémáért én felelek, de a
munka, az érdem a kollégeimé, mert ők
dolgoznak alapvetően. Én szélzkedek az
egyetemnek most. Én körbejárom a
világot, meg az országot, meg nyitom a
kapukat az egyetemnek. És
ez a hitem, hogy ez a tempóváltása
BML-nek. Ez
szerintem nem tudom kívülről mi látszik.
Biztos egy ekkora szervezetet nem lehet
egyik napról a másikra átállítani, csak
így nagy hajót, ezért forogni kell kis
idő. De a fürgébb jellegünk szerintem
már kezd kezd kijönni. Most mivel az
első év azzal telt, hogy a külső
paremfeltételeket
megcsináltuk,
most jönnek a belső folyamatok. nagyon
sok rossz belső folyamatunk van,
bürókratikus. Ezeket szépen lassan ki
fogjuktatni életünkből. Most építjük.
Tehát most a második éve a a
rektorságomnak
azzal telik, azzal fog telni, hogy a
belső folyamatainkat rendbe hozzuk.
Minden, ami fölösleges fék, bürokrácia,
fölösleges adminisztrációt kizetnénk
gyomlálni a rendszerben.
>> Apropó, most mekkora az aránya az
adminisztratív munkatársak és a az
oktatók között? A 3000-t hogyan
osztanánk szét?
>> Durván fele fele. Fele fele. Picivel
több az oktatókutató.
És apropó zárójelben sokan, akik hittek
a közalkalmazott, de én sose hittem
benne, mert én nyomortáblának szoktam
hívni.
És engem irritált mindig is a
közalkalmazotti lét, de én sose tagadtam
ezt. Tehát a kollégeim tudják, hogy ez
nem a kedvencem.
amikor
megtörtént, február 28-án volt az utolsó
közalkalmazotti státuszú napunk,
és
egy kollégám, aki a közalkalmazói
tanácsot vezette, akkor azt mondta
nekem, ő úgy méri a a váltásnak a
sikerét, hogy hány százaléka a
kollégáknak lép ki.
Mondtam Csaba,
szerintem senki sem fog kilépni.
>> És mi lett?
>> Többen lettünk.
Március 1-től szeptember 1-ig 55-tel
többen vagyunk a karokon. Nem a központi
aparátus, hanem a karokon. Na most ha
így nézem,
hála Istennek
a kollégák, ez a mi kezdetben szerintem
alaptalan félelem kezd. Nem azt mondom,
megszűnt, de kezd csökkenni.
Persze biztos
ez ez a transzformáció biztos
bizonyos zökkenőkönnek kell, hogy
átmenjen, mert nem létezik, hogy ekkora
szervezetnél nem lesznek ilyen vitás
kérdések satöbbi. Ezeket majd megoldjuk.
Ma ahogy érzem annyira erős az
immunrendszere az egyetemnek, hogy ezt
meg fogja tudni oldani. És én ettől nem
félek, mert a kollégeim értelmesek és
pontosan tudják, hogy az a célunk, hogy
az egyetemet előratoljuk több
tekintetben. És szerintem ez a cél, ez
minden BM dolgozó fejében ott van. És
ami még erősebb, nagyon jó a
kapcsolatunk a hallgatókkal. Ezt tudni
kell, hogy a BMN
a hallgatóknak vagy a hallgatói
képviseletnek nagyon erős jogosítványai
vannak.
Amit mi megtartottuk ezt a fajta
erősjogosítványt.
És de ők partnerek voltak abba, minden
ami az egyetem érdekét szolgálja,
partnerek voltak abba, és támogatták. És
neki köszönettel tartozom, mert mert
belátták azt, hogy az, hogy mi langyos
vízben vagyunk, ez lehet, hogy kényelmes
egy pár napig, de ez vissza fog ütni,
hanem ezt a kicsit
tempósabb működést, ez mindenkinek
jót fog tenni a hosszabb távon. Az egyik
kérdés így felmerült, miközben így
beszéltél, hogy
ez ez rengeteg kompetencia kell, ami nem
csak tehát, hogy neked van egy
tudományos háttered, de a vezetői
képességek meg az ezek átlátni ezeket az
adminisztratív folyamatokat, ezeket te
valahol tanultad, vagy belenőttél ezekbe
a folyamatokba? Hogy hogy hogy
>> mind a kettő? Igaz,
>> mind a kettő.
Amikor azzal kezdtem, hogy a a
ranglétrán végéig mentem, voltam
tanszékvezető, voltam DK, voltam
csoportvezető előtte.
Tehát végigéltem ezeket és láttam a a
problémákat,
>> a folyamatokat belülről. Igen. És nekem
van közgázdiplomám, ezt nem a 90-es
években. És amikor készültem a amikor
eldöntöttem, hogy beadom a rektori
pályázatot,
beiratkoztam egy ilyen leadership
képzésre Oxfordon, amit távolról
végeztem, és ettől nagyon sokat tanultam
és
merem azt mondani, hogy
tehát maga a leadership képzés nem fogja
tudni velem ismertetni a a az egyetemi
folyamatokat. Ez azért ez az előny, hogy
én benne voltam több szinten ezekben a
folyamatokban. Szenvedtem sokat ezektől
a folyamatoktól,
és
viszont ezek a képzések rávilágítanak
egy-két dologra, egy-két ilyen paternra,
egy-két sablonra, hogy mit hogyan kell
csinálni. Nem kell a spanyol vast
feltalálni ezekben a témákban.
És a éppen az oxfordi képzésnek ez volt
az erényje, hogyha szabad így mondani.
Nem szoktam ilyen más egyetemnek a
képzését dicsérni, de a korrektséghez
hozzá
hozzátartozik, mert ez ez benne van,
hogy a olyan volt az egész képzés, hogy
saját szárióval kellett végigmenni
hétről hétre.
>> Akkor adta magát, hogy ezt a
>> adta magát. Én a saját esetünket néztem
végig, hogy akkor más szemmel, aki
kívülről jön, hogy látja ezt az egész
folyamatot. Tehát ez a mentor vagy
konzulens, aki segíti a munkámat, akkor
hogyan tudja értelmezni, amit én leírtam
és ilyen formában. És ő független nem
kell nevesíteni, csak mégis le lehet
írni a saját
esetét az embernek. Tehát én úgy
gondolom, ez nagy segítség volt ezekhez
a a kérdésekhez.
Nem kell nekem mindenbe belefolynom,
mert a mikro menedzsment megírja, megöli
a menedzsmentet. De kezdettől fogva én
úgy voltam vele, szeretnék benne lenni,
legalább belelátni, hogy amikor a
kollégáim jeleznek valami problémát,
megértsem, hogy mennyire fájdalmas tud
lenni. Én is döbbentem. Azt hittem
magamról 39 év műegyetemen mindent tudok
az egyetemre. Tévedtem.
Nekem is voltak új elemek, tehát csak
azért, hogy korrekt legyen az ember
ebben. Én is volt egy két pár esetem,
jé, ez miért így?
Nem ugrott be előtte, nem találkoztam
vele, satöbbi, satöbbi. Tehát nekem is
voltak új elemek, de egy szó mint 100
én úgy gondolom, hogy
a vezetésnek a velejárója, én szakmával,
kutatással most nem foglalkozom,
nincs időm rá. Egy dologról nem mondok
le, ez a tanítás, ez az életem. Szeretek
tanítani.
Ez ez motivál. Ez tartja bennem a
lelket, hogyha fiatalok között vagyok
heti két alkalommal kétszer két órában.
Ez nekem nagyon fontos
motivációs elem és
ne legyen félreértve. közvetlenül is
szeretném
látni a a visszajelzéseket, és mindig
szoktam megjegyzéseket tenni, miet a
rektor nem vette észre, hogy ebbe a
teremben meleg van, és akkor növetünk
egyet, és megyünk tovább. És akkor
amikor hazamegyek vissza az irodába,
akkor azt mondom a az XYZ illetékesnek,
hogy akkor ez most mi van? Miért miért
miért van 30 fok egy teremben? Mi is
miért fűtünk? Tehát vannak ilyen
visszajelzések. Én a terepen vagyok. Én
mérnökképzettségű vagyok. Tehát én
szeretek a terepen lenni, és a terepen
az ember az autentikus visszajelzéseket
tudja megkapni. És azért is jó a
tanítás. Ezenkívül, hogy hogy a
lelkemnek jót tesz, hasznos is több
tekintetben.
>> Amúgy kételkedni nem szoktál magadban.
Egy egy hatalmas szervezetet vezetsz és
hatalmas következményei vannak. A nemzet
nemzetet fogod képezni. A a BMI a nemzet
nem te, hanem hanem a a BMI fogja a
kollégák. És
>> kétely nincs benned, hogy esetleg
tévedsz ebbe az irányba?
>> Mivel ilyen baráti hangulatban vagyunk,
és nem ilyen hivatalos bejelentésekről
beszélünk, akkor hadd mondjak pár
dolgot. Az első év,
ez ami most nyáron lezárult, nagyon sok
alvás nélkül éjszakán volt, hogyha
hogyha nyíltan beszélünk.
De furcsa módon ez nem abból fakad, hogy
nem jó, amit csinálunk. Mi van akkor, ha
egy kavics kerül a gépezetbe?
Mi van akkor, ha menet közben megáll a
folyamat? Mi van akkor, hogyha vagy a
partner, a mól, vagy a a kormány
meggondolja magát, és az fú, ez így nem
satöbbi? Mi van akkor, ha bármilyen
oknál fogva megáll az a folyamat adott
helyen, és akkor hog mi lesz a válaszom
rá? Ezek foglalkoztattak.
Ha ez a bizonytalanság, akkor ez
bizonytalanság. Ezt nem tudom másképpen
éremezni. Leírom ugyanúgy, ahogy én
éltem, hogy ne ne adjak neki gyűjtő
fogalmat. Nem tudom, hogy hívjam, de az,
hogy nagyon sok életemben nem volt ilyen
nehéz évem, mint ebből én jó alvó vagyok
mellesleg, és van tükröm, nézek mindig a
tükörben. Tehát lelki ismeretem nagyon
szigorú velem, de a itt a kevés olvás
alapvetően
inkább a az aggodalom adta, hogy valami
nem tud végigmenni.
Tehát láttad magad előtt a víziót és
annyira jó nap látom, hogy mi lesz a
második évnek a vége és a veszélyeim
micsodák. Van egy szervezet, mindig azt
szokták mondani a leadershipban, azt
mondják, a change management a
legnehezebb, és főleg a de én úgy
gondolom, egy okos populációban vagyok
közepén.
Én azt mondom, nem szeretem azt a szót
tetején, mert én nem főnök vagyok, hanem
kolléga. Nekem most éppen ez a szerep
jutott, de ez a ez sokáig ez egy egy
voltam a az 1500 közül, aki akadémiai
staff kategóriába tartoznak. Most az,
hogy nekem jutott ez az első erre az öt
évre ez a szerep, hogy én lássam el a
rektöri szolgálatot, nekem ez egy
szolgálat.
Öt év múlva, vagy most már négy év múlva
lezárul. Az, hogy pályázok vagy nem
pályáz, az majd a jövő eldönti.
De lényeg az, hogy ez egy De én úgy
érzem, és ezt hagd legyek önző ebbe és
önző is leszek, én egy maradandót
szeretnék alkotni. Olyan maradandót.
Van egy kolléga akadémikus, akiből
szoktam időnként beszélgetni és adók
szavára, és ő annyi egy dolgot mondott
nekem, ő nem merte volna aláírni ezt a
szerződést,
hogy bátor vagyok, hogy megléptünk ebbe
az irányba. Tehát vannak ilyen ilyen
semleges visszajelzések, őszinte
visszajelzések,
amik elgondolkodtatnak néha, hogy mi
van. Csak én mindig azt szoktam nézni,
rendben van. Mi az alternatíva?
Ezt kipróbáltuk sokáig. Fejlődés nem
történt. Éltük a mindennapokat,
elvégeztük a munkákat. Hálás vagyok a
kollégáknak, hogy minőségi munkát
végeznek. Rendben van. De nekem ez nem
elég.
Ez az én szememben a BMS szintjén. Az a
langyos víz. Teljesítettük amit, nekünk
kelletteni satöbbi, magunk szintén, de
nem volt benne challenge, nem volt benne
olyan, hogy akkor többre vagyunk
képesek, törekedjünk magasabbra.
>> Tehát a langyosvíz az rosszabb, mint a
kudarc. Ez
>> ez rosszabb mindennél.
Bocsánat, és hadd legyek most éles és
lehet, hogy bántó leszek. Elnézést érte.
Ha rosszul sül ez a modell, még mindig
jobb, mint a langyos víz. Annyira nem
hiszek ebben a langyosvízben,
mert előbb vagy utóbb az épületeink nem
fiatalódnak.
Állami sapkában ebből a pénzből ki
szoktatok jönni. Tessék most is és
próbáljatok kijönni belőle.
De ez nekünk fáj, ha mi nem fejlődünk.
Ez a mi egyetemünk.
Nekünk ez nem állás. És én nem akarok
senkit bántani, és a múltkor lehet, hogy
bántó voltam egy-két esetben, amikor
kancellárt kívülről hoznak be az
egyetemre. A kancellárnak ez egy állás,
három év, négy év, öt év, ameddig élvezi
a a miniszternek a bizalmát. De nekünk
ez nem állás, ez életforma.
Nekem a gyerekem azt mondom, majd amikor
nyugdíjast leszek, mondja, apaal, te nem
leszel nyugdíjas, te bent fogsz meghalni
az egyetemen. Tehát saját gyerekeink is
ezt ezt predikálják nekünk előre. Tehát
ez ez az életforma, ez a fanatizmus az
életem iránt. Tehát nekem meg nem
megterhelő 12 órát kell hoznom az
egyetemet, mert szeretem ezt a ezt a
légkört, szeretem ezt az egyetemet.
Akkor is, ha régi épületben ülök,
szeretem ezt a millőt, mert mindig
emlékeztet a nagyságra, az elődöknek a
bölcsességére. Amikor megcsinálták ezt a
az egész konstelláció az egész helyen, a
Budapest legszebb helyén terül a BM.
Kevés egyetem mondhatja, hogy egybefüggő
ekkora kampusza van. 313000 nmünk van
45000 nm laborkapacitás.
Ez egy drága képzés, egy egy drágám
fenntartott környezet. Nekünk becsülnünk
kell, mert az elődők azt mondták, ez a
nemzet műszaki egyetem,
és ezt nekünk, ezt az örökséget tovább
kell vinni. Most október 23-át
ünnepeljük, vagy megemlékezünk az
elődökre. Onnan indult az 56.
Én most a kollégáknak itt több kolléga,
amikor az ipari kollégákkal
beszélgetünk, azt mondom, minden út,
minden jó út a BMR-re vezet. De ez nem
túlzás. Itt több kolléga, akivel
tárgyalunk partnerként, cégként, azt
mondom, könnyű dolgunk van, mert az
asztal másik oldalon egy volt BMS ül. Az
esetek többségében egy volt BMS ül az
asztal másik oldalán, hogyha tárgyalunk
szakmai emberekkel. Tehát bocsánat, az
adottságunk megvan,
ezt nem olasszuk el, erre érdemes
építeni. És aki ott végzett, most is a
következő beszélgetés kis Gergelyér,
Gergely is ott végzett. Tehát ezért
könnyűek ezek a a a bevezető részek,
mert nem kell nagyon bemutatni az
intézményt. A múltkor volt egy gépészeti
konferencián, ahol meg felkértek, hogy
nyissam meg. Odamentem és azt kérdeztem,
ki végzett BML? És 150-ből 140 körül
emelték a kezüket.
Tehát mondom, jó, akkor ezt a pár száot
átlapozom, nem mutatom be. De ez
komolyan, mert úgy érzem, ez előny, egy
helyzeti előny. Bocsánat.
Ez hűtlenkezelés, hogyha valaki nem épít
rá. És a vezetőnek az a szerepe, hogy
tudja, mik az erős pontjai az
intézményének, és erre építse a
stratégiáját meg a jövőjét.
>> Ezt ezt érdemes megismételni. Ez hűtlen
kezelés az, hogyha valaki nem épít erre.
Ez egy erős kifejezés.
É tökéletesen én is így értettem senkin,
>> hanem hanem gyakorlatilag ezt az
önbecsülést éreztem benne, hogy emberek
ére lássátok, hogy mekkora kincs van a
kezünkben. Hogyha nem használjuk ki ezt
a kincset, akkor olyan, mintogyha
hűtlenkezelők lennénk valójában. A
ülengkezelés ez erős szól, mert nem
tudok jobb fogalmat, előzést, ha lehetne
jobb fogalmat, ak nem bántásképpen
szánok, csak úgy gondolom, hogy butaság
lenne nem erre építeni, vagy bocsánat,
vezetési hiba lenne nem erre építeni,
mert ez egy helyzeti előny mindenkivel
szemben.
És én úgy gondolom, hogy többen vannak,
akik így gondolják ezt a az
>> lehet ez egy félre is félrecsúszott szó,
de mégis van benne valami, mert valahol
nem csak lehetőség abszolút nem csak
lehetőség, hanem valahol ott van a
kötelesség is.
>> Abszolút. És különben nem érdemes
vállalni. Még egyszer,
>> aki azt hiszi, hogy a rektor csak fú
nagy dolog, nem ez egy feladat, nagyobb
felelősség. És az előbb bevallottam az
előző évnek, vagy az nyárig tartó évben
nagyon sok nap volt alvás nélkül.
>> Amúgy a le is jegyeztem a úgy úgy
fejezted ki magad, hogy hála Istennek és
mondtál utána valamit, hogy te egy
vallásos ember vagy?
Mondhatom, hogy igen. Igen. Magam módján
igen. Most ú betartja úgy, úgy nem
tartom be úgy, hogy az ceremóniákat meg
ezeket a részeket nem, de a lelkem
mélyén igen hiszek Istenben, és úgy
érzem, hogy ha tisztességesen csinálom,
úgyse lehet rossz a vége. És nekem ez a
hitem. Van ebben egy ilyen
küldetéstudatod is, hogy hogy
>> nem nem akarok egy ilyen mélyíteni és
nem akarom a személyemhez kötni. Tehát
ezt én két dolgot szeretnék mindenképpen
kiemelni. Amiről beszélek, amikor én
képviselem, mert most éppen én
képviselem az egyetemet. Amikor
beszélünk az eredményről, ez az
egyetemről szól. Nem rólam. Én csak ez a
kapitány vagyok most, aki navigálja a
hajót, de a hajó maga viszi az egész
terhet. Nem én. Én csak segítem ezt a
dolgot, és ebbe a szerepbe töltöm a
szerepemet. És senki sem pótolhatatlan
ezt a ez másik
>> pótolhatatlan ember és én szeretnék,
hogy szeretném, hogyha olyan lenne a
modell, aki jön tovább viszi. És amikor
úgy érzem, hogy és most amikor ezt nem
titkolom, amikor az alapító okiratot
újraírtuk együtt a fenntartóval egy
dolghoz ragaszkodtam. Tartsuk be ezt a
szabályt,
nem kötelező, hogy két ciklus lehet, ha
rektor csak. Söet magamtól kell védenem
az egyetemet, hogy hátha meghűrlök,
hogyha na ne na ezt ezt ha tényleg
valaki szereti az intézményét, beépíti
ezeket a védelmi reakciókat az a a
>> saját maga egójával szemben, mert az
ember torzulhat és emberek vagyunk,
bármi történhet, azért pont vé védelem
is legyen a a az a szervezet vagy az
egyetem védelmében, érdekében. Így egy
év után, hogy látod, hogy torzított-e
rajtad ez a hatal nem volt annyi idő,
hogy mert mert nem volt még még nyugtom
egy napig sem. Tehát, hogy úgy úgy
érezzem, hogy ezt végiggondoljam.
Szerintem az első öt évben az a veszély
nem áll fön, mert az első ciklus. Majd
ha jelentkezek a második ciklusra, akkor
már kezdünk erről beszélni, hogy akkor
ez a védelem mennyire jogos volt. Most
minden esetben, ha most az NFTV, tehát a
felsoktatási
törvényben benne van a két ciklus az
államinál, ezt mi megtartottuk, bár
senki sem kényszerít minket rá, és én
ragaszkodtam hozzá. Azért, úgy érzem,
pont azért ne arról szóljon, hogy egy
emberről szóljon ez a dolog. Ez az
intézmény, ez nagy örökség. Ez a nemzet
öröksége, az, hogy ki viszi, melyik
időben, az csak egy így jutott a szerep.
Neki szavazott bizalmat a szenátus, de
ez nem azt jelenti, hogy ez az ő. És a
teljesítmény nem az én érdemem. Az én
időmben szerencsés leszek. Én is
hozzáteszek valamennyit. Ez 1/1500 az
1500-ból.
És plusz a nem oktatókutató ugyanilyen
aranybeg 3000, mert azoknak a szerepe
felbecsülhetetlen. Tehát azok a
kollégák, akik viszik az egész
adminisztrációt, az egész előkészítést,
nélkülük nem tudnánk a kutatást,
fejlesztést és az oktatást rendesen
megcsinálni. Nekik hálával tartozom,
nekik is. Én nem szeretném, hogyha egy
személyről szóljon az az egész.
Az, hogy aki most úgy gondolja, hogy nem
találtatok egy magyart, amiről
beszéltünk akkor, akkor ő is egy szint
után nézzem
bele, hogy itt nem az, hogy ki honnan
jött, ki mit tesz a a nemzeti kincsért,
a műegyetemért,
ki honnan hova viszi az egyetemet.
Legalább a cél az, hogy menni sikerül,
ez még korai nyilatkozni.
Csak van egy dolog, lehet, hogy
félreértelmezhető, de akkor is kimondom,
őszintén beszélünk.
Egy percig sincs két kétségem, hogy ez
nem jól fog működni a a jövőben is. Ez a
meg furcsa. Ez az érzés sose került elő.
pedig minden nap nézem a tükröt, hogy
akkor vajon hátha szól nekem azzal
kapcsolatban, hogy hogy
>> nekem ami tetszik abba, ahogyan beszélsz
és amit mondasz, az abba az tehát én úgy
tudnám ezt össze
>> próbálok lassan beszélni, hogy ne
hadarják,
>> hogy hogy és gyanítom, hogy ez ez
tetszik a a munkatársaidnak is, és
gyanítom, hogy a hallgatóknak is, akik
majd valószínűleg hallgatni fogják ezt a
podcastet, hogy ez az önbecsülés, amit
amit mondtam az elején, szerintem onnan
jön És lehet, hogy majd kijavítasz, vagy
vagy hozzáteszel még valamit, hogy itt
valójában ez egy szolgálat, amit
kiemeltél és egy küldetés. Tehát
gyakorlatilag minden egyes hallgatónak
küldetése van. A azért mennek a BMW-re,
mert az aki megtanul írni, megtanul
kritikusan gondolkozni, megtanul
tervezni, megtanul beszélni, az
egyszerűen legyőzhetetlen lesz. Tehát
itt most nem arról szól a BMW, hogy
kapjanak munkát, miután elvégezték. Ez a
mondjam úgy, ez a triviális része, hogy
fognak munkát kapni. Hát persze fognak,
mert szükség van rájuk, de de nem azért
fognak majd munkát kapni, mert
nem azért tanulnak, hogy csak munkát
kapjanak, hanem azért tanulnak, mert
gyakorlatilag a a következő generáció,
akik utána így alapozza meg a következő
generációt, így így hozza be azt az
innovációt, így fogja gyakorlatilag
legyőzhetetlenné válni a világban egy
újabb és újabb területeket meghódítani,
és ez a fajta önbecsülés árad belőled
így, ahogy beszélsz, hogy hogy nektek
küldetésetek van, szedjétek össze
magatokat, váljatok méltóvá arra, hogy a
BMW tagjai vagytok.
>> Igen, az én ilyen szépen nem tudtam
összefoglalni, csak egy dolgot azért
kiemelnék.
És ezt a már ismétlés
lesz, de nem baj, inkább ismétlem.
Ezen a a ha küldetés ezen a célon nem
vagyunk kevesen BM-n belül. Nagyon sokan
vannak hallgatók is, meg a többiek is.
Biztos vannak szkeptikusak, és mindig is
lesznek szkeptikusak. Vannak kis hitűek,
akik nem hisznek saját magukban, hogy
mire képes az egyetem.
És ez azért mondom, mert ez a
megközelítés, amit mi követünk, ez BML
specifikus. BML találta ki ezt a
modellt. BML merte meglépni ezt az
egyedi modellt,
ami hibrid a privát és az állam együtt.
és pont olyan célból, hogy
megvalósuljanak ezok a célok, amik
előttünk vannak. És
hogyha megnézem a szerződést most, amit
kötöttünk az állammal,
nagyon sok lehetőséget, nagyon sok ajtót
nyit az egyetemnek, hogy tudjon
megújulni. Azért én azt azt nem
megújítás, mert nem jön kívől senki és
megújít minket. Mi megújulunk belünkről.
azért nem megújításnak hívom, hanem
olyan fent fenntartóváltási
időszakon vagyunk, vagy vagy műveleten
vagyunk túl, ami nyitja a kaput a
megújulásnak. Tehát mi újulunk meg, mi
rakjuk össze a rendszert belül, és ha
lehet, akkor nagy szabadságunk van
abban, hogy ez törvényes keretek között
értelemszerűen, hogy ez ez megvalósuljon
a a jövőben.
Természetesen ahhoz még sokat kell
dolgozni, még nem állt be a rendszer,
még nem stabilizálódott a rendszer
ahhoz, hogy azt mondjam, hogy hú, ez a
már a vég még mondom az első, a külső
részt csináltok, most a belsőt
csináljuk. Tehát sok munka van még
ebben,
de minden lehetőség megvan ahhoz, hogy
ezt így folytassuk és sikerrel vigyük.
>> Következő hat év most már úgy nagyjából
felvázoltad, hogy mivel fog telni
rengeteg munkával, de úgy látszik
nagyjából kijelölve az út odáig.
Kérdeznék egy ilyen merészet, nagyon
kíváncsi vagyok a vélem. neked nincs
tabu téma,
>> hogy
hogy látod, hogy 50 év múlva hol lesz
vagy a BMW, de nem csak a BM, hanem
egyáltalán maga az oktatás milyen
irányba fog alakulni. Ugyanis azt látom,
tehát például ezelőtt 50 évvel, tehát
hogyha most egy 50 évvel ezelőtti
időszakba megyek, akkor nem volt ez a
globális elérése senkinek. Tehát
gyakorlatilag, ha valaki tanulni akart,
akkor egy ilyen egyetemhez tartozott, és
és akkor teljesen más státusban tanult
valaki. 50 évvel később egy
okostelefonon már el lehet érni az
Oxfordnak, vagy a Cambridge Egyetemnek a
a kurzusait, és 50 év múlva hol lesznek
ezek a hatalmas oktatási intézmények?
>> Mi nap válaszolnék erre rá, hadd hívjam
a figyelmedet.
Van egy oldal, fejből nem tudom a címet,
de elküldöm majd, megkeresem. Akkor
berakjuk a leírásába a videónak ezt.
>> A a francia
tudósoknál 1900-ban megkérdezték tőlük,
hogy mi lesz az oktatás jövője 100 év
múlva 2000-ben.
És ez egy festmény vagy egy kép
formájában, lehet, hogy láttad már ezt,
ez régi, nem új,
azt mondták, milyen lesz az oktatás 100
év múlva. Nem 1000, hanem 100 év.
>> Nagyon kíváncsi vagyok, milyen
>> és akkor azt rajzolták, hogy valaki
fejhallgató van. Valaki a könyvet
beteszi egy gépbe, bedarálják egy gépet,
és így megy a tudás a fejbe. Ezt nem
mondom 100 évvel ezelőtt
Franciaországban, nem több 125, mert
1900-ban.
Tehát ez akkor úgy gondolták, hogy a
technológia úgy fejlődik, hogy az
emberbe így fogják beinjektelni vagy
bejuttatni az információt. Szoktam néha,
amikor Brazil csinálok, ezt a képet pár
pár helyen már vetítettem, és vajon
bejött-e vagy sem, ezt mindig ezt a
kérdést tesszük föl. Visszatérve a
kérdésre,
a mostani generáció már egyértelműen
bebizonyította nekünk, hogy
mi nem lehetünk statikusak.
Az azt jelenti, ő a mostani generáció.
Most nem akarok én most alfa z, tehát
nem akarok semmilyen ilyen
társadalomtudományi
kifejezéseket használni, melyik a
mostani generáció, aki most az értelemen
van, ő nem jobb, nem rosszabb, ő más,
mint mi. Neki a trigger körnézete más,
mint a miénk. Ő ebbe a most szemléletben
hisz. Ő nem ér rá holnapig jutni. A
gyerekem az utolsó perc percben érkezik
a a buszmegállóban. Én inkább ott várok
öt perc, mert biztosra akarok menni. És
mind a kettő magam ugyán eléri a célt,
fölszáll a buszra. Csak más a
megközelítés.
A a mostani generáció tehát kicsit más.
És azért, hogy lekössem a figyelmért,
mint oktató, ez a frontális oktatás, ez
gyengül. Tehát abból a szempontból nem
tudraktív lenni több tekintetben most.
Nem 50 év múlva, még csak mostról
beszélünk. És ha így nézem, akkor most
mivel a mostani konferencia a AI
szellemiségben lett felépítve az egész
program, akkor az AI eszközök így
fejlődnek, ilyen formában terjednek.
beszélünk arról, hogy a csipet iktatnak
és bekötik a a szervezetben. Tehát a
mesterséges és az a természetes
elemeknek a az integrálása. Ez már
elindult, ha szabad így menni. Én a
francia példával élve az, hogy hogyan
juttatom az agyba vagy a fejekbe a
tudás, ilyen ilyen ebbe az irányba
megyünk a a hosszabb távon. Az azt
jelenti,
hogy a mi környezetünkben az állandó
változás, állandó adaptálás. Mi
adaptáljuk a módszereinket, a
megközelítéseinket, a mondanivalóinkat
a változásnak megfelelően.
Vannak olyan elemek, amik statikusan
feltételezem, hogy bárhon bepötyögi és
ez nem biztos, hogy neki kell mondani.
Egy dologról nem tudunk lemondani, hogy
kreatívan álljanak hozzá a kérdéskörhöz.
merjenek, kritikusak lenni a fiatalok,
gondolkodjanak,
és még fontosabb, legyen önbizalmuk. Én
mindig, amikor találkozok egy egy-két
fiatallal az a lépcsőn, az a központi
épületben, és látom kicsit így szomorú
mondom, mosolyogni
és önbizalommal járni. Tehát azt
>> hogy lesz valakinek önbizalma? Így
elmesélted, hogy a te mentorod az, aki
téged
>> én nekem segít a sokat. Igen.
>> Úgy. És itt kön a felelősségünk is
egybe. Nekünk ezt sugározni kell. Nem
tanítani, sugározni kell az önbizalmat.
Ez csak úgy lehet. Felkészülten megyünk
előadásra,
hitelesek vagyunk, amit nem tudunk, azt
mjuk utánanézzünk. Ez nem nem szégyen.
Ez a hitelesség, ez nagyon fontos.
A eleme, hogy tanítsuk valakinek, hogy
partnerként kezeljük. Ez erősíti az
önzalat. Nem vagyok társadtudós. Biztos
társamudó megcsáfolna, hogy nem így
kellene lehet, de én úgy gondolom, hogy
emberszámba partnerként kezeljük a
hallgatót. Nem másodrendű állampolgár.
Meghallgatjuk, neki is ötlete van.
Interaktívabbá teszem a a beszélgetést
és sugalom neki, hogy neki a véleménye
fontos. E ez nagyon fontos, amit
elmondtál, mert egy
>> nem vagyok társadalomtudós, még egyszer
ezt nem tudom bebizonyítani, de így
állok hozzá, így értem én én ezt a
megközelítést.
>> Én egyetértek vele, és én se vagyok
társadalomtudós, de hogy valójában amit
mondtál, az az, hogy felkészülten,
kompetensen mész be a az órára, ez egy
fontos dolog. és azt üzened, hogy te
képes vagy arra, hogy ezzel a
kompetenciával megbirkózz, hogy képes
vagy arra, hogy tanulj, hogy hogy
levizsgálsz, és hogy hogy egy kompetens
személyé válte is.
>> Nekem mesterszinten
van egy tárgyam, és mindig csoportba
szoktak szoktam előírni a házi
feladatot. Volt egy időszak, ami ti
ittották engem a kollégáim erről. ö mind
a 150 ember vagy 160 ember, tehát 50
csapatot végighallgattam mindenki 10
percet a a házi feladatot, minden
csapatot, és azt mondom, mindenki
szólaljon föl legalább három percre és
több többüknek azt mondja pocsék,
hát hát végigdolgoztál vele és nem tudod
nem tudsz engem meggyőzni. Az te ülsz és
nincs kedved, nincs önbizalmad. Ezt
szoktam visszacsatolni nekik.
Lecsesztek engem a kollégáimet, hogy azt
mondja, most miért kell? Na most ez
azért van, mert ha én nem hiszek egy
dologban, hogy akarom sugározni a
többiek felé? Ha én hiszek az életem
jövőjébe, akkor sugárzik belőlem a
hallgatók felé, hogy én ebbe az
életemben hiszek, meghalok érte.
De ha úgy megyek be, hogy kedvtelen
minden a minden életbaj már a fejem
fejemen van, mi terhelyem ezzel a
fiatalokat.
Ezzel mi rontjuk. Nem az, hogy erősítjük
az önbizalmat, romboljuk. Tehát én úgy
érzem, nekünk van más kötelességünk is.
Itt azt szoktuk mondani, a mérnöki
képzésben a soft skill meg a business
skill meg kell, hogy legyen. Mellette
tanítanunk kell, és krediteket
definiálunk, hogy milyen kurzusokat
tanítunk. Én én az ebben benne van az,
hogy együtt hogyan dolgozunk, hogyan
kommunikálunk, hogyan prezentáljuk, amit
csinálunk.
Ön azt szoktam mondani, te töltötted
ezzel a legtöbb időt, tehát pontosan
tudod, mi van vele, de hát te se hiszel
benne. Akkor miért várod el tőlem, hogy
én higyek benne? Te nem is nézel a
szemembe. Nem mersz a szemembe nézni,
mert nincs
nincs hited ebben, hogy ez sikerül.
Tehát ezt a fajta
önbizalmat, ez nem tud úgy, úgy úgy
beinjektelni és tanítani a könyvből. Ez
a cselekvések sorozatán keresztül
keletkezik az emberben. És ez a
visszacsatolás nagyon fontos az ember.
>> És ez az, ami 2050-ben se fog, vagy
bocsánat, 50 év múlva se fog
>> szerintem az az, ha már mindenki
megteszi a dolgát és mindenki próbálja
ezt a fajta üzenetet átadni, akkor
lehet, hogy már nem lesz nagy gap, amit
amit de ha nem figyelünk oda, de mert ez
a világ, vigyázni kell, mi a kütyükkel
élünk együtt. Ez a veszély, ez nagyon
erős tud lenni, mert nem kontaktálunk
sokat másokkal, mert bezárkozunk ebbe a
virtuális világba. Tehát itt duplán
dupla a felelősségünk. Tehát azért
jobban kell ezt a a megközelítést
követni, hogy az önbizalomban segítsünk
a fiataloknak ilyen területen. Még
egyszer, én most egy olyan területre
navigálok, ami nem az ilyen területem,
nem vagyok társadalomtudós. Most
mentegetőzésben nem szeretek belemenni,
csak én így állok hozzá és így
értelmezem a az én oldalamról ezt a ezt
a megközelítést.
>> Lassan a végére érkeztünk a podcastnek.
Lenne egy kérdésem még a a BMI jövőjével
kapcsolatban. El tudod képzelni, hogy
más országokban is megjelenjen a BM?
Többek között például itt Székelyföldön?
>> Már konkrét lépések vannak ebben mi az,
hogy el tudom képzelni, az biztos be fog
következni, csak időkérdése. Nem csak
Székely Székelyföldön is
>> mert beszélgettünk tegnap a a itt a
kollégákkal, de azért külföldön is. A
>> konkrétumot mondhatsz most ebben a
pillanatban? Sajtóba szerepelt, hogy a
Dubaiban vagy arab Emirátusokban van egy
ilyen beszélgetés, hogy lesz egy
brendünk, egy officeunk, egy irodánk
satöbbi. Ezen dolgozunk most. Tegnap itt
egy kolléga azt mondta, ő azt olvasta,
hogy mondom, igen, a az emelet követte
el az első lépéseket, már megtettük ebbe
az iránybe, hogy nézzük meg, hogy hogy
meg. Én szeretném, hogyha a BM
terjeszkedne, csak most a a prioritás
nem az. A prioritás, ahogy mondtam, a
belső folyamatoknak a tisztítása,
racionalizálása,
kigyomlálni az összes bürokráciát és
stabil
szintre juttatni a modell működését.
Utána nyitásban egyszerűbb lesz a
ráépíteni egy stabil modellre, mint mint
most, amikor még még még felszállópályán
vagyunk.
Utolsó kérdésként azt tenném fel, hogy
itt most itt vagyunk a digitális
Székelyföld konferencián.
Valójában van esélye egy ilyen kicsi
Székelyföldnek vagy Magyarországnak a
globális IT piacon nyerni és és úgy
részt venni, hogy hogy tényleg komolyan
vehetőek legyünk?
>> Remélem tudod a válaszomat. Én a kis
hitűséget nem szeretem.
Nekem a a Kolumbsai nálunk végzett,
tehát itt többen, ezért ott végeztek
nálunk. Erre mondtam minden, hogy jó út
a BML-re vezet. Tehát ez ez hagyd legyen
legyek szerény a BML-vel kapcsolatban
sohasem leszek szerénybe, mert van mire
büszkének lenni és van mire alapozni. De
én úgy gondolom tegnap a vacsoránál azt
mondtam a kollégáknak, egy cél van, hogy
itt őrizzük ezt az értéket helyben. Nem
az a cél, hogy innen elvigyem Budapestre
két még két fiatal, és ha elvis viszem
oda, akkor jöjjön vissza ide. Tehát az a
cél, hogy ez a
ez a környék életben gazdag maradjon, és
ezek a fiatalok találják meg a
boldogulásukat
itt. Ez csak akkor lehet, ha globális
piacon tudnak érvényesülni. Az IT szakma
ez nem helyhez kötött szakma. Hogyha
digitális konferenciáról beszélünk, itt
szoftveresek informatikusakban meg
zömében, vagy informatikai
vállalkozásokat képviselnek. Innentől
kezdve ez nem helyhez kötött. És mint
ilyen, minden esély megvan, sőt
konumbensani példáként ő azt mondta
nekem, kezdettő fel, amikor ott
doktorált én nem fogok itt maradni,
visszamegyek haza.
És ez azért fontos, ez egy jó jelzés, és
mondjuk egy azt szoktuk mondani,
egymérés, nem mérés, de mégis egy jelzés
arra, hogy igény van arra, hogy az ember
saját otthonában, hazájában, ez erről
szó, mert Magyarország is hazája, de
saját otthonában is megtalálja ezt a a
megélhetőségi, boldogulási lehetőség, és
minden esély megvan. És én most négyzer
vagyok itt már négy. Ez a negyedik
konferencia, hogy vagyok itt. És minden
évben azt mondom, jó élménnyel megyek,
különben nem jönnék még egyszer. És azt
látom, hogy életképes ez a ez a
környezet. Egy kis támogatásra van
szükség. Ezt mi támogatjuk ezt amiben és
tegnap is kifejeztem, hogy a külhani
magyaroknak a segítése ez nemcsak a a
magyarország stratégiája, hanem
szerintem aki hosszabb távon
gondolkodik, nagyon sok székelyi földi
gyerekünk van, hallgatónk van itt a
kollégáknak mindenki gyerekem is odajár,
gyerekem odajár, ez nagyem eletleg nem,
hanem 22000 hallgató. Nem akarom ezt a
10%-öt elcsalni, csak azért ha már
beszélünk, akkor legyen korrekt a dolog.
>> Ö. Én úgy gondolom,
én arra biztatnék mindenkit, hogy
itt próbáljuk teremteni ezt a
segítséget, és nem kell elmozdulni
sehova, mert ez a gyönyörű környék, ezt
kell lenne hagyni csak úgy emiatt, mert
nincs itt lehetőség és ilyen kis
hitűségben lenni, hogy itt kis helyen
vagyunk, távol vagyunk, jó az internet,
jó az infrastruktúra, én nem látok itt
ekkora problé jó a megközelítés is.
Tehát ebből a szempontból, bár lehetne
két járatnap ponta a Vizerrel, de de
azért lehet ide elég hamar jutni, tehát
ez már nem gond a távolság.
>> Ez egy tökéletes mondat volt Zárszónak.
Köszönöm Hassán, hogy elvállaltad ezt a
beszélgetést. Én nagyon élveztem.
Remélem a hallgatók is fogják úgy
élvezni, ahogy én élveztem.
>> És várunk jövőre is a digitális
székelyföldön.
>> Köszönöm szépen a meghívást és örömmel
jövök. Köszönöm szépen.
>> Köszönöm.
Az utóbbi időben nagyon sokat
foglalkoztat a startupok világa, nagyon
sokat foglalkoztat az oktatást téma, és
a következő pár epizódomat erre
szeretném szentelni, meghívni a legjobb
vendégeket, akik meg tudnak szólalni
ezekben a témákban. Ha szeretnél
támogatni ebbe a munkába abban, hogy
ezeket a témákat minél inkább ki tudjam
bontani, és a mögöttük rejlő alapelveket
meg tudjam érteni, és ezt podcast
formájában veletek is megosszam, azzal
tudtok támogatni, ha feliratkoztok erre
a csatornára. Azt vettem észre, hogy
körülbelül 80%-a a nézőknek nincs
feliratkozva a csatornára. Gyertek és
iratkozzatok fel. Ez nagyban segít és
motivál engem is, hogy tovább folytassam
ezt a kutatást, és ezeket az érdekes
témákat hozzátok is elhozza.